sur les principes de cette Révolution : produire efficacement.
Pour que les produits, c'est-à-dire les patients,
quittent l'hôpital le plus tôt possible.
Au cours du dernier siècle sont apparues beaucoup d'innovations intéressantes.
Nous avons trouvé le moyen de faire de l'insuline.
Nous avons inventé les pacemakers et les scanners.
Nous sommes même entrés dans l'ère de la thérapie cellulaire et génique.
Mais le plus important changement pour réparer notre système hospitalier
nous attend encore.
Il est temps de révolutionner entièrement le système
et d'oublier notre système hospitalier actuel.
Il est temps de créer un système basé sur les soins de santé à domicile.
Des recherches récentes ont montré que 46% des soins hospitaliers
pourraient être faits à domicile.
Ça fait beaucoup.
C'est surtout pour les patients qui souffrent de maladies chroniques.
Ainsi, les hôpitaux pourront et devront se transformer
en centres de santé plus petits, agiles et mobiles
portés sur les soins spécialisés.
Des choses comme la néonatologie, le soin intensif, la chirurgie
ou l'imagerie resteront à l'hôpital, au moins pour l'avenir proche.
Il y a peu, j'ai vu une collègue
dont la mère a été diagnostiquée d'un cancer incurable,
et elle m'a dit : « Niels, c'est difficile.
C'est si difficile de savoir qu'il ne lui reste que quelques mois à vivre.
Au lieu de jouer avec ses petits-enfants, elle doit faire trois fois par semaine
le trajet aller-retour de deux heures jusqu'à Amsterdam
juste pour obtenir son traitement et ses tests. »
Ça m'a brisé le cœur,
car on sait tous qu'une infirmière professionnelle
pourrait lui faire une prise de sang chez elle
et si elle pouvait avoir ses tests et son traitement à la maison aussi,
elle pourrait faire ce qui est vraiment important pour elle
durant ses derniers mois.
Ma propre mère a 82 ans, que Dieu la bénisse,
évite d'aller à l'hôpital
car elle estime difficile de planifier et de gérer le voyage.
Donc, mes sœurs et moi, on l'aide.
Mais beaucoup de personnes âgées évitent les soins,
attendent si longtemps que ça devient dangereux
et elles doivent recevoir des soins intensifs coûteux.
Dr. Covinsky, un médecin chercheur à l'Université de Californie,
a conclu qu'un tiers des patients de plus de 70 ans
et plus de la moitié des patients de plus de 85 ans,
quittent les hôpitaux plus handicapés que lorsqu'ils sont arrivés.
Voici un problème très concret,
auquel plein de patients doivent gérer lorsqu'ils doivent aller à l'hôpital :
« Où aller avec mon meilleur compagnon,
mon chien ? »
C'est notre chien, en fait. Elle pas super mignonne ?
(Rires)
Il ne s'agit pas seulement de confort.
Il s'agit aussi de séjours inutiles et de leur coût.
Un de mes amis, Art, a récemment dû être hospitalisé
pour une petite opération
et Il a dû rester à l'hôpital pendant plus de deux semaines,
juste parce qu'il avait besoin d'un antibiotique intraveineux spécial
Il a occupé un lit pendant deux semaines,
qui coûte plus de 1000 euros par jour.
C'est tout simplement ridicule.
Ces coûts sont vraiment au cœur du problème.
Nous avons constaté dans beaucoup d'économies,
une augmentation des frais médicaux en pourcentage du PIB
au cours des dernières années.
Vous pouvez voir qu'au cours des 50 dernières années,
les dépenses médicales ont augmenté d'environ 5% en Allemagne
à environ 11% aujourd'hui.
Aux USA, l'augmentation a été de 6% à plus de 17% maintenant.
Une grande part de ces coûts est due à
l'investissement dans de grands et nouveaux hôpitaux.
Et ces bâtiments ne sont pas flexibles,
ils maintiennent un système où les lits doivent être remplis
pour que les hôpitaux fonctionnent efficacement.
Il n'y a aucune incitation pour qu'un hôpital ait moins de lits.
Rien qu'y penser rend malade, vous ne trouvez pas ?
Le coût du traitement de mon ami Art à la maison
aurait pu être dix fois moins élevé qu'à l'hôpital.
C'est vers cela qu'on se dirige.
Le lit d'hôpital du futur sera dans nos propres maisons.
Ça a déjà démarré.
Les soins à domicile dans le monde augmentent de 10% chaque année.
D'après ma propre expérience,
logistique et technologie rendent possible le fonctionnement des soins à domicile.
La technologie nous permet déjà de faire des choses
qui auparavant n'étaient que dans les hôpitaux.
Les tests sanguins, de glucose, d'urine,
peuvent désormais faits chez soi.
On constate un nombre croissant de dispositifs connectés,
comme les pacemakers et les pompes à insuline,
qui enverront un signal en cas de besoin urgent.
Toutes ces technologies participent à fournir davantage de données
sur la santé du patient,
et ces informations assurent un meilleur contrôle
et moins d'erreurs médicales.
Souvenez-vous, c'est la 3e cause de mort aux USA.
Je le vois chaque jour au travail.
Je travaille dans la logistique.
Pour moi, les soins à domicile fonctionnent.
On a un livreur qui amène les médicaments chez le patient,
une infirmière l'accompagne et fait les injections chez le patient.
C'est aussi simple que ça.
Vous vous rappelez de mon pote, Art ?
Il peut maintenant avoir ses antibiotiques intraveineux chez lui :
pas de pyjama d'hôpital, pas de nourriture de médiocre,
et sans risque de superbactéries résistantes aux antibiotiques
que vous n'attrapez qu'à l'hôpital.
Ça va plus loin.
Les personnes âgées peuvent maintenant obtenir les soins dont elles ont besoin
dans le confort de leur propre maison,
avec leur meilleur compagnon dans la vie.
Désormais, ce n'est plus la peine de conduire des heures
juste pour vos traitements et vos tests.
Aux Pays-Bas et au Danemark,
nous avons été témoins du succès des centres anticancéreux
qui organisaient des chimiothérapies à domicile,
parfois même avec d'autres malades.
Les meilleurs améliorations pour ces patients
ont été de réduire le stress, les troubles anxieux et la dépression.
Les soins à domicile les ont aussi aidés
à retrouver un sentiment de normalité et de liberté dans leurs vies.
Ils les ont même aidés à oublier leur maladie.
Mais vous me direz : « Les soins à domicile, Niels--
Je fais comment si je n'ai même pas de maison, si je suis sans abri ?
Ou bien si j'ai une maison mais personne pour prendre soin de moi
ou même pour ouvrir la porte ? »
C'est là que rentre en jeu notre économie de partage,
ou comme j'aime l'appeler, « l'Airbnb du soin à domicile ».
Aux Pays-Bas, les églises et les organisations de soin
mettent en contact des personnes en manque de soin et de compagnie
avec des gens qui peuvent fournir un toit, des soins et de la compagnie.
Les soins à domicile sont moins chers,
plus faciles et rapides à mettre en place dans les zones rurales,
et aussi lors de crises humanitaires
où c'est parfois plus sûr, rapide et moins cher de faire les choses à domicile.
Les soins à domicile s'appliquent bien dans les zones prospères
mais aussi dans les collectivités mal desservies.
Ils fonctionnent dans les pays développés
aussi bien que dans les pays en voie de développement.
Je souhaite améliorer la vie des patients grâce aux soins à domicile.
Je souhaite faciliter les soins pour les personnes âgées
dans le confort de leur foyer,
avec leur meilleur compagnon de vie.
Je souhaite provoquer ce changement et aider les patients et non leur maladie
contrôlent leur vie.
Pour moi, ça passe par les soins à domicile.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)